well you sent me this so okay this is an
older one and i think since
now first off shout out to kitty b and
victor bontroom
d-lob dot tv slash the victor show uh
because
all right look guys it takes a village
to raise an idiot if you understand what
i'm saying
so uh you have to uh
since since we've been needled on the
facts and lying
uh we've taken a a bit more patience and
time
with the channel and some things were
dug up
last night so i think i've i think i've
properly set this up for you okay so
this one's called iowa scam for naked
pictures
that happened
um this is before us yeah by the way
this is to show that it was not just us
[ __ ]
this was this was a this is before us
i made a mistake this morning
a couple of weeks ago
a person offered me money
for naked photos
i have sold pictures in the past
to a friend that i knew very well
sold pictures to a friend and
what kind of pictures like a dick in a
shoe
hey
hey i gave those out for free
you did no just never mind
inside jokes ladies and gentlemen
because i am homeless
and i am struggling and the idea
of a little extra money that i don't
have to beg for was enticing
so i sent a picture
and of course there was no payment
and now i just feel used
you should because first off get the
payment first dummy
always get the money first i wasn't
going to care
you know because it's not that big of a
deal
it's just a picture does that say nadex
who was who is sending this
i don't know oh she's sending bleeding
pics too what
next pick i will send will be of me of
my bleeding
i deserve she's threatened to hurt
herself every time
i deserve to believe for stupid enough
to think to get a single dollar from
this so she she
she threatens a dollar she threatens his
side a lot huh
for a dollar you gave up the pictures
for a dollar and didn't even get the
dollar first
have you ever seen the budget where uh
the lady of the night
is uh getting a face destroyed and then
all of a sudden the guy finishes and
runs off
that is her
by the way that's an allegation that's
not a [ __ ] fact
yeah so you don't want to be called a
liar i don't want to be caught a liar
i'm just making jokes on the internet
guys
but then when they actually didn't pay
it
it became a big deal you know pay for
the
first pick no because i want more one
i'll send money you stop bugging yes i
would have been blocked you after the
sent
after i sent the first pick so this
guy's really just trying to get more
pics out of her
so see
they were trying to be nice last year
this is someone that's been pushing this
for a while
hey was it was it me because you accused
it of me
you dumb [ __ ] every yeah it's it's
it's always it's always us
it's it's even before we were talking
about her yeah
don't let people get to me stop
okay so then he changes and says send
nudes for money
how fat are your tits this
holy [ __ ] just ram it right in there
nadex
hey is that executed that's a you sent
executie over there you son of a [ __ ]
how fat are your tits
i gotta be honest man i just i don't
i don't wanna see it don't
i don't know if that gets my man card
taken and i'm no longer allowed at the
outpost i'm okay with it
this was almost a year ago
you know well 58 days ago he was still
asking
hey for the record we haven't asked to
see you naked once
i don't want to yeah i don't want that
royce is happily married i've been with
the same chick for like 15 years we're
both good over here but we might be fat
but we could pull better [ __ ] than
healing
years ago when i was really struggling i
asked if he was still
willing to pay and he said yes
i need to answer quicker even though it
took three days
you remember when she was like oh i'm
gonna hurt myself because of you
she she we're seeing a pattern here
right
yes it's a pattern yes for him to
respond
you know fifty dollars
i sent my paypal so 50
all right so roy some some other guy got
titty pics for 50 bucks and you got
access to her entire [ __ ] you know
archive of content
i honestly i'm i got a steal obviously
because honestly i'm looking at your
goal wave down there and you're about to
double your [ __ ] problem well you
know what thank you for bringing that up
jj
what a great producer you are um it's
almost like you've never worked with one
like me that does any work actually
behind the scenes
i actually remind you to do things that
you should be doing anyways because
you've been doing this long enough and
you're just
you know hey we're like the same age
[ __ ]
all right let me let's play this
yo what do we have here a huge
spacecraft pulling up to the [ __ ] ship
ram ranch what are those letters i see
n-i-g-g-a
[Music]
you better not lose your stream labs too
[ __ ]
also can you dm me the discord where
men's play valheim
in the market for some new gaming boys
the valheim stuff once they
i'm gonna once they open it up to more
than 10 people on a server at a time
i'll try to get more people in but right
now it's just 10 people so
can i say this real quick before you
play the next one sure
i think our next gaming stream should be
all right and i'm gonna i know you have
it i have it
and the dustin tv has it we should get
the zombie squad together
and [ __ ] roll out and ride
in call of duty world of war world war
cold war whatever the [ __ ] call of duty
it is i don't give a [ __ ]
yeah i'm down i'm down i'm always down
to play some call of duty
you set it up yeah we could do that i'm
absolutely down to do that
i'm down all right uh
let's see here just one more i think
troopers i just received new orders
love the mayo head content thank you so
much lord loaf he gave
20 bucks enough and tachi 2 just to give
a shout out 51
which was very nice that's one dollar
more than i paid for this
i've already made my money everything
after this is profit
i think i'm starting to re-uh
re-evaluate
um our original deal because
like i originally said that this is
going to come off of
um the package deal that i got a while
ago that got beyond
behind on because of cobit but i think
that's been paid back now i got to say
we're starting to get into that uh
territory i'm sorry i'm sorry how many
ninja genies have i given you
um maybe three or four yeah so let's not
speak and pretend
royce royce i can't take ninja genies
anymore so we have to renegotiate that
too
wow this isn't a good [ __ ] gordon
gecko over here
[ __ ] comes on and he starts now hey
listen what are you going to do pawn
your microwave to make me feel bad your
[ __ ] face
i'm gonna pound my air fryer though i
actually want that
um see royce likes me because he doesn't
have to split anything with me
i will no you know what i'm gonna send
you some money today i'm gonna send you
one dollar i'm gonna be like there you
go
[ __ ] hey well i've hit the go away
for today already folks
cut it out and shut it off
maybe if you cried and threatened to
kill yourself i give you money have you
thought about that
all right next time we're about home and
you need help [ __ ] you
ah [ __ ] man god damn it by the way a
server that i pay for
hey how much is that by the way it's 45
for three months hey that's not bad nah
it's actually not bad for what would you
get it's not bad
yeah it's not bad what's your email i
sent the email i sent one pic
to prove that i would
and then asked for the money before i
sent more
do you have a fat ass too he'd know she
took
your ass and you'll get money i'm not
sending more pictures for free
i've already sent one
so why would i scam you why why scam a
homeless woman of her dignity
you know humans are garbage that's why
why else i mean i agree
yeah i mean i could get on board with
that humans are garbage you're right
absolutely as long as we're there so are
you too right yeah just saying
mary welcome to the club yeah
down here we all float
well she really spams that paypal link
yeah a lot
i'm going to actually pay me you know i
know that
like once it didn't come through for the
first picture i knew that there wouldn't
ever be any kind of
but you see you guys were saying oh look
what you're doing to her
this is what she's been doing this this
grift she's been doing this bit for a
while
all right this isn't anything new
this is something that has just been
going on
for a long time and she tried to put the
blame on us like we were the first
people
all right all right i need to ask what
is the ratio and how long ago was this
this is october 1st 2020 and the ratios
one
up eight down oof
oof that's not good yeah
but there was a picture
i did oh that was the picture first i'm
like
please don't that would [ __ ] come on
you got to warn us
yeah let down my barrier enough to take
a picture
you didn't let down your barrier enough
you were selling your nudes
that i sent to this person
that i thought
was going to help me get through this
life
to help me get a little bit of weed and
a good meal today
i was willing to sell off my dignity
can't sell what you don't have yeah i
was about
that was the exact line i was just
trying to figure out how to order good
job bros yeah
just for a hot meal
like they get those away for free lady
yeah especially you're in la man that
you could go to a food bank at any point
yeah and they'll give you boxes of food
and and they even serve hot meals in the
park like every day
they fought to be able to feed you and
you don't want to stand in line is the
problem
because you pissed off the entire line
and they all wanna you know
and in the end it's not really gonna
matter they're going to share
that picture all over the place why
i haven't looked why i don't first of
all i don't want to see it i won't be
clear here
i don't want to see it i don't care
about it
nobody at least that i know of wants to
see it
nobody i mean look curiosity killed the
cat and sometimes you must do things for
science
no no no no no
no and i don't know if if i'm being
clear enough so
[ __ ] no oh this is a good one
oh this one's so good so this is when
the way back this is from 2018.
ladies and gentlemen i need you to
stretch all right everybody take a nice
stretch
all right crack a couple things all
right
and i think we're all ready this is from
2018.
she was a little chunkier back then hey
hey
hey stop calling her fat right i didn't
call her fat i said she was a little
chunkier that's not fat
i know she's one of us one of them one
of us
one of us
oh you know you should have a beard now
enough that i felt like i needed to make
a video about it
i just got home from church from what
church no yes
church no she didn't no she did
you can't tell she's got the cross on
her chest there it's not the medallion
pendant that she's uh
peddling now hey look jj she's one of us
now
one of us we have neck fat
and chunky lips one of us
i'm going to get so much use out of this
50 bucks well smith but it's a good
great deal good deal
i'm still all sparkly from church
and hey ree okay
so on the last friday of every month
our church has music they have a singing
act come
it's what singing
music come well that's when they come up
there
and then they sing and then they come
it's called the aristocrats
but it's the church edition got it it's
always fairly nice
last month we had the new floridians and
um that was actually the night that i
gave my life to jesus christ that was
the night that i became now she's
religious
where she was before huh
seems like she's a lot of things that
are always going on i'm saved
since then i've been to church every
night that they have church um
sunday mornings sunday nights wednesday
nights thursday nights
sometimes friday nights i'm always there
i'm up at the church helping whenever i
can
or going to the nursing home to visit
people whenever they come to pick me up
to take me
i have not had any problems with this
church i have
since i started going to this church i
have felt nothing but love
literally i have gotten more love from
this church than i have received yes
if we were in the discord i would be
playing this
i don't hear anything no no no i can't
play it because we're not on the disc
we're not on discord we're in skype's
have to send it to you to play so check
your check your
check your check your discord
where where if we were there i could
have played it but
oh god you're right
live rounds
[Music]
762 millimeter
metal jacket
hi joker from anybody in my life
ever so i don't
i really really don't like what happened
tonight even more
because it makes me think badly of these
people
that up until tonight have done me no
wrong
but tonight we had a singing group come
in
um the harper brothers there was a lot
of people there was
probably 70 people there i've never seen
that many people in that church
cool because the harper brothers are
very famous get through their act
and go to collect the collection plate
which is a love offering for their
payment
and they say that uh they want to talk
about something real quick
and they pull out this petition and they
start asking people
to sign this petition to stop
jacksonville from converting bathrooms
to unisex bathrooms
good while they're talking about this
i'm looking around and seeing all of the
people that have been
so good to me cheering
and yeah and they don't want
[ __ ] you're an elizabeth you're in a
church bathroom with their daughters
yeah but the thing is like you're in a
church like what do you expect
yeah in jacksonville okay look podunks
live right up the road
excited enthusiastic
about this horrible
thing that they're trying to pass why is
it horrible
now i guess most people wouldn't be
upset about it i think probably there's
more people wanting the bathrooms to
stay gendered than there are
wanting it to be neutral and
yeah i'm co-signing that i don't want uh
weirdos
in women's bathroom sorry it's not
it's not progressive it's [ __ ]
disgusting and i don't want women in
men's bathrooms making me pee shy
listen it hits me so strongly is because
my first husband
here we go here it comes
everyone's sitting down ladies and
gentlemen i told you to stretch
now it's time to strap in is everybody
sitting down
strap in everybody put your folding
tables up your weed
away make sure you keep uh drinks away
from your computers or laptops because
it's about to get
fun please stand clear of the doors
the reason it hits me so strongly is
because my first husband
the man that i fell in love with and i i
just i know what's coming
and i i i hold on
hold on where is it ready here we go
here we go
it hits me so strongly is because my
first husband
the man that i fell in love with and
married
the only one that i've married i haven't
never been remarried i've never felt
that way about
anyone else to want to get remarried
kitty cat
sorry come on where's misty oh come on
come on come on
oh anyways i've never felt that way
about anybody else
so he is still very much in my heart
okay and he is transgendered
he i should say she is living as a woman
now
so he is still very much in my heart
and he is transgender
the cat's head needs to spin around
what
[Music]
um
um i'm sorry every time i look up i like
respect
sorry and
he is transgender he i should say she
is living as a woman now that's hard for
me to accept
i'm not going to lie i use the wrong
pronoun
because i married a man and in my mind
it's just it's difficult for me to
accept but
that's not the reason we separated that
seems like a big reason to separate
though right
like i would say it's pretty big yeah
that seems like a big reason
supported i think my old lady would get
excited if if that actually happened in
our relationship the fat [ __ ] chance
that that's gonna happen but
some people would be down with that you
know there's there's all kinds of people
out there they like things
the crossover i supported everything
that he
she went through the reason we broke up
was because i was being cheated on
and abused but that's nothing that's not
here nor there
it should be everything there but
so you so she turned away from she went
to church she turned away from god
because her husband was trans
well no she turned away from the church
because
they wanted unisex bathrooms and her
white guilt makes her feel sorry for her
ex-husband that cheated on her
i think i got this right i'm sure she'll
correct us
i still love my first husband
and i always will and
because i still love him i will defend
his right to use the bathroom he can
yeah a men's room no one's going to stop
him
they have turlets in there you could
stand or sit
yeah if he feels ashamed [ __ ] sick
i know that people don't like hold on
jason fritz wait
she was married to barley quinn oh no
we figured it out no
transgendered people i'm aware of the
hate and especially here in the south
i'm aware but
it bothers me because they're not doing
anything to
you at all how is
how is having a male and female bathroom
doing anything to you
yeah i mean you're how is forcing a girl
that doesn't understand
what the [ __ ] going on to have to deal
with that
and by that i mean it and by it you know
what i mean
my husband becoming a woman
hurting you how is
a man peeing in a woman's bathroom
hurting you um
i could come up with about 18 different
scenarios but they're all underage
yeah there's a lot of reasons why this
shouldn't be happening even of age
nothing forget even of age there's a lot
of reasons that should have been
happening
because think about there's a lot of
damaged women out there
you're let me set the stage you're
you're you're in a nightclub okay
you're in a nightclub and uh here i'll
play some i'll play some nightclub music
so so let me let me walk you through one
of them you're in a nightclub
music's bumping you're out there and the
you know you're a woman you're drinking
you're having a good time you ubered
there you're not gonna drive right
you walk into the bathroom and then
another drunk man
i will not say his ethnicity also is
drunk
and then now you're in a bathroom with a
man
who's getting handsy with you and
grabbing you and then he has every right
to be there
because your husband in my opinion
couldn't stand it so much that he became
a woman
i mean that's a good reason right
and then then this is why the outpost is
so great jj
because there's only one bathroom at the
outpost of men's room
you're not gonna have to worry about
getting sexually assaulted if you're a
woman there that's for [ __ ] short
well that's because they make the women
pee outside that's right like where they
deserve to be like dogs
well that's where they're at yep so
and i know people will scream oh but
they're pedophiles oh but
our children aren't safe if you think
your child is not old enough to
defend itself go into the bathroom with
your child what a [ __ ] hot take
hot take incoming
okay phil can i call you phil um
you're wrong on more levels than you can
ever understand
and being white guilt uh
is not okay okay
having white guild is not okay being
woke
is not okay it's not
jesus it's mentality you know it's safe
don't you
why is your child in public if it can't
defend itself
are you i don't know maybe because it's
in a stroller you [ __ ] psycho
are you [ __ ] serious right now maybe
they're [ __ ]
six or seven and not strong enough to
[ __ ] find it up
but yet if one guy even walks into your
apartment inadvertently
you screech and re like the [ __ ]
you are but angel's got a good point you
shouldn't have to defend yourself in the
bathroom like
you know what i mean you dude you do
duties in there water go down the hole
nice plucky duck reference yeah
and if your child is not out in public
alone then why aren't you going into the
bathroom with them
to keep them safe because there are more
children molested
in bathrooms by people of their own sex
than there are by people of the opposite
sense because right now
currently bathrooms are set up where
people of their own sex
go to those bathrooms um
but statistics royce don't mention
statistics cause they get mad when you
start talking statistics right
you know what i mentioned fbi statistics
around here
but most of the molestation that happens
to children happens from family members
it's not happening in the bathroom just
because your experience
dicta dix takes your life
um doesn't mean that that's how it is
for everybody everybody's different
everybody has a different road in life
uh royce was propositioned and on a
cruise ship
okay that's correct so uh you know i've
had my own
interactions with it uh and i was a
large enough fat kid to fend them off
but there are little brothers of the
world
who can't defend themselves and need the
help of the big brother if you
understand what i'm saying that's why i
always walk around with nunchucks
and yeah hell yeah nunchucks
dolls bathroom at walmart there's not
transgendered pedophiles
hanging out waiting um there but there
are
the pedophiles that these children are
having to fend off
are their own fathers or uncles
or friends of the family
i know this from experience
i knew she was going to say that we all
saw that coming huh
again this is the problem it happened to
me
so it's the only way it can happen it
doesn't happen any other way
are we getting our dollars worth so far
you think uh yes sir i'd say you made
your money
i believe that we're getting our fifty
dollars worth